ya know welcome to a new video this will
be somewhat different um because um in
reply to one of the Blitz game so I got
a request to to do videos on end games
and it's especially and game strategy on
general principles so not basic end
games with the reduced material but
somewhat more complicated positions was
with more material on the board well
strategic planning is required yeah of
course is some not a really easy subject
so if I would cover all this decently it
would be a lot of videos and I simply
don't have the time to do a full
coverage of of different subjects now so
what I'll do is some I'll make them just
one one example pretty interesting one
which illustrate some a very basic
endgame principle and this is some
principle of two weaknesses and also I
recommend a specific book that is pretty
much yeah maybe the best book or at
least the most recommended book if it
comes to the subject of endgame strategy
and this is some rather notebook I
looked it up and tuck it out of my own
my library here and the one one I have
here of course it's in German but it's
from 1985 the one I have um the original
publication on 1981 and it's by an
international master Mahad Jerry Scheff
scheme this is named put the name and
details of the book also in the in the
video description so you can can
we look it up on on Amazon or whatever
it's not um really huge book my German
version years got me a close to 200
pages but the author does a great job of
selecting very instructive examples and
groups and nicely into common common
themes I just quote some some chapters
here
it's like centralization of the King
problems with exchanges pawn play in the
endgame thinking in schemes principal of
two weaknesses and so on I think um this
is really a very very good book with
this some kind of subject what you need
to know about the author because then
most likely you know that won't know him
I tried to dig out some some information
about the author and it proved pretty
difficult it seems that he made his
international master master title in the
70s and then basically retired from from
practical play to become a trainer so um
if you read their own international
master and know they have so many of
them and well he was pretty strong
international master back then with the
rating of about 2500 if I haven't found
it correctly and back then and rating of
2500 meant something like top 100 in the
world so he wasn't a bad player at all
and back then it was some pretty young
yeah what was in was a lot more
difficult to get the Grandmaster title
so it's um it's not a big deal that he
it's not a Grand Master for instant
world famous Russian trainer argued leap
the most famous trainer and chess marvel
wretzky is also just an international
master so yeah I can recommend this book
Apple
and I'll show one example from this book
and actually when I got the suggestion
of this theme I immediately thought of
this book and also of this example
because I remembered it that that I
studied it I don't know 50 15 20 years
ago or something and I was quite
impressed by the the clarity of the the
plans here from from an old game 1922
played in London between pronunciation I
don't know of two world champions
Alekhine and Andover
so I got a pretty high profile battle
here the book actually starts on with
this position which is on the bottom and
why to move it's the 17th booth so it's
just after the opening move amid some
yes I'm mistake and actually ended up in
this pretty horrible position of course
the main feature of the position is the
difference between whites excellent
knight on e4 and blacks dreadful bishop
and g7 you can see the bishop is very
much limited by the pawn on e5 and also
blacks pawns yeah are all already on
dark squares on the Queen side which is
some not a good not a good sign and of
course black also has got the very weak
double pawns here on e5 and e6 which
also mean that the knight only form has
got a brilliant outpost will never be
removed by any piece there but it's um
it's not completely easy to find a way
to make progress let's just play a
couple of Museum
right now plate Brooke f.2d won an
important point here is that black
responded king of aid it's not able to
play C 5 C 4 which is a dark desirable
move in general to put pawns on light
squares the opposing color of the bishop
to give the bishop more room maybe come
to f8 and do something along this
diagonal here this is not possible here
because of a simple technical reason
white has just 926 and when will we win
the pawn on c4 and this is just an extra
pawn and all the positive sides about
the position on still exists and that is
still better can return to you from so
black cannot play C form breaking of 8
wide went King f1 which is in general
desirable to get the King in the center
no black went King is 7 and now it's a
pretty important point white needs to
recognize that C 5 C 4 is really a
threat from from from black side so
white plays an important move C form now
black plays a 6 H 6 sorry I actually
skipped one important point I'm sorry on
King um on King f8 sorry the set of King
of one white would have had the
possibility here to play Knight g5 which
is not good because of King is 7 and if
white now takes on h7 black would have
the possibility to play on Bishop h6 and
the knight would be trapped and could
only be saved for playing a move like h4
and for instance rook h8 95 and like
gets rid of its bishop and he happily
gives up a pawn
for this so this shouldn't shouldn't be
played
why shouldn't well um like the English
expression yeah
he shouldn't be content was with such
small potatoes so to say he should keep
the positional advantages so as he form
like now played h6 kingi - no black
exchanges one pair of rooks
now good now the key point here in this
game and this is about the obvious move
rook d8 black played rugby aid but rook
da does some very essential point as you
need to check what the position is like
if rooks I exchange this is a is a
general consideration here not just in
this position even even after that
because the pawn structure is very fixed
and you need to consider on what this
end game is like is it winning what what
are the plans there and in fact route d8
allows the exchange of rooks and it is
completely winning after that and this
is very impressive because some it shows
some that White has a very clear plan to
win and this is a principle introduced
in this book that you need to think in
different stages of making progress in
such a position it's very static and you
can basically think what's what is the
next stage of progress you you can
achieve let's put the exchange on the
board so what would white like to do the
first step here would be to change the
setup of the knight and the king
one thing is the night is very pretty
only four but it doesn't detect any porn
okay it takes a look on the c5 pawn
which is protected and that's nice but
you'll never win this pawn it's a good
idea here at the first stage of the
important plan to get the King to e4 and
the knight to d3 exactly to d3 to double
attack the e5 pawn I'll just make moves
to to get to this because blanket simply
cannot do anything what starts with b3
that's all I'm not backwards of course
King b3 king bee 792 what's the quickest
route Knight to c3 King e79 to a4 d7
into e47 b2 King d7 93 King G six of
course in the game you don't need to
calculate the seven or eight moves you
just need to envision this position
after the exchange of rooks which you
can always always achieve the move p3
was necessary to get the square b2 for
the night to get this route complete to
d3 and if you look at this position
beforehand you will see that is that is
almost as oops wrong position black
cannot move the King because it loses
the e5 pawn so black is pretty much
reduced to moving the Bishop from gt72
h8 or f6 and he cannot do anything
anything else you cannot do any
meaningful meaningful moves with pawns
or something it's just a position where
you don't have any moves so what would
be the next step you need to get a
second weakness and this is achieved
by pushing the kingside pawns white goes
h4 in this position and this leaves
black with the dilemma what what should
he play now he cannot play a move like
g5 that's why it would just exchange and
switch the night over and black will not
be able to keep those pawns this would
be a complete super Swank for instance
Bishop f6 g4 you see em f3 I know black
cannot move anything and you can
steadily improve further here what what
should like do let's say a three a six a
four a five and now what just needs to
get rid of the the right to move and
black will lose the pawn so he cannot
play something like g5 what else could
you do we could play h5 and then White
has the nice move f4 which gets rid of
the e5 pawn this is not nice it was a
good weakness but if you look at this
position white would simply pick up the
g6 or h5 pawn this is the nice thing
about this since never I have four it
opens up the way from the knight to
attack the King side so black cannot
play h5 so what can you do just sit and
wait then g4 h 5 again loses because of
taking f4 and this pawn is gone not g5
so it's all it's all very
straightforward and let's say now like
exchanges here stays put an f4 and again
you see that the G's takes pawn is
falling it's it's completely completely
straightforward black is tied to the
weakness on e5 and simply cannot cannot
do much well white is strengthen
position so was so usually on the King
side that he will win or
of those pawns and black cannot do
anything to prevent it and this is very
important once you've recognized that
black cannot exchange the rook because
it simply always won because of this
manoeuvre you simply don't need to
calculate this possibility anymore you
can just when the possibility crops up
you can just exchange rook and transpose
to this kind of endgame structure
okay black cannot play up the eight so
he plays rugby eight just awaiting move
so what now the maneuver on the Kings
side which I described could be he could
be tried as well but the problem is that
with the rook on it's not to just this
sit and wait position black can can do
much more than two to fight in this in
this position so why should try to make
progress first on on the other side so
white goes rook d3 which has the idea we
will see immediately playing a4 and then
try to create a new weakness on the
Queen side black cannot do anything rook
c8 rugby three King b7 and now a5 and
now we see that black cannot capture an
a5 because I move like group b5 would
pick up those pawns so there's not much
else to do black needs to allow this and
now look a 2 a 3 and white has managed
to open up the Queen side and can now
enter with the rook either on the
eighth-ranked or the seventh rank black
goes Bishop g7 silly cannot do anything
b5 was also not possible because of the
simple check here and after King move
white just kept scoops white just
captures on b5 and and wins upon in
addition c5 is also basically gone
so this is not possible like just stays
put
rook a7 and now replace rook c7 in this
position actually it would be rather
thematic if Alec Anya now just would
have exchanged yeah he didn't because he
thought I guess that the way he played
was equally strong but in this position
you white simply could could capture and
play exactly as I described after the
Rubik's change because it doesn't really
matter that the a pawns are missing it
would have one brother easily just as
just as shown but an account like rook
a8 with the idea of swinging the rook
over to to g8 yeah this move also has
its points because if you look carefully
oh sorry
flex bishop simply has no moves and what
he does is he continues to to attack
here the various weaknesses until they
fall Ruki seven now rook c8 check King
d7 g8 and black is simply reduced to
waiting he cannot do anything and now
white gains the space on the on the
Kings side which also also shows them
the principle which is some shown
numerous times in the book and this is
some very famous one by now but it was
pretty much introduced and popularized
by this book and this is the slogan I do
not hurry this kind of positions don't
do anything in a quick fashion just stay
calm and think about improving the
position first very often you have the
time to play improving moves first and
then when much easier it might take a
little bit longer because you
to get all the improving Muhsin but it's
much safer win than try to calculate
everything to the end with forcing
variations so why just first does
everything to improve its position goes
over to them to the queenside place b3
black is simply not not able to do
anything just calmly improving and now
he goes for g5 fixing all the weaknesses
note that this very much complies with
the strategy outlined after the rook
exchange so rook exchange would also
still lead to the kind of winning plan
with King on d4 Knight on d3 and f4 so
now with the perfect position of the
rook on g8 which completely dominates
the bishop it doesn't have any move at
all um no white even can bring the king
up here I now activates the knight and
continues the text on the pawns on b6
and d6 actually lead to to win over pod
right here because black cannot cover b6
anymore
of course okay if he covered it but then
e 6 was warning and next move also g6
and so on basically our points are
falling and black ism is losing easily
so this was a nice example of of
planning in the endgame what what you
really need to keep in mind is this type
of position here and it shows that in
this kind of static positions where you
got a static advantage of a knight
against the bishop here for instance
that you can really think of from single
steps improving the position further and
finally
as shown here breaking through with the
move like oops like effort to win to win
the porn yeah those thanks for watching
this video I think it was a nice example
of demonstrating two weaknesses one
weakness was very obvious in the
beginning the the bet Bishop on g7 and
the pawns which on e5 and e6
which in a way yeah one weakness because
some the bishop on g7 is a weak because
of the the pawn formation but it shows
that in order to win you need a second
weakness in in case of the rook exchange
line this was some the pawn on for
instance here g5 or the Poland on g6 or
each of our h5 this weakness was created
by advancing further on the Kings side
and the way the game was played the
second weakness was a b6 pawn and also
the weak 7th rank so the more active
rook Lex rook was simply reduced to just
just a put on the seventh rank and black
wasn't able to move anything so you need
to create a second weakness to win
usually one weakness is not enough so um
yeah I think I'm this book it's it's
well known by now and already a classic
thirty years old
but still very much when it when it
comes to to training and game strategy
so if you are interested in the subject
and to think it's it's a very fruitful
field of study
um I think you should try to get this
book um yeah have a look at the the
description of the video well put in the
exact term data about this yeah thanks
for watching and also um yeah be
encouraged to to make suggestions about
new videos
of course do more of these some
commutated blitz games which would be a
steady feature of the channel but it's
very welcome if you have specific
suggestions for other subjects so just
write me a message on write a comment in
the video so I can pick up ideas them
yeah thanks for watching and see you in
the next video